big time win for the Titans in Houston
and they are in the playoffs and they
includes a good friend of this program a
man who helped blow open the holes for
Derrick Henry the league's leading
rusher in 2019 and he is also one of the
co-hosts of a podcast called busting
with the boys would be much better if
the bus from which the podcast emanated
had an actual motor under the hood he's
Taylor the one how are you Taylor I'm
great rich
I'm electrostatic to be here and we
almost made it all the way through with
an intro without you insulting me a
little you know it's not an insult I'm
actually trying to make it better for
you Taylor you know I'm trying to
improve it's odd that you would take it
negatively no no I feel you know what
it's after you hear something so many
times so many people come at you for the
same reason you have to finally making
changes the bus is getting an engine
things are working out but more
importantly Derek Henry is a Russian
reader 2019 and that's pretty cool yes
let us talk about that taylor LaJuan why
did things work so differently with
Tannehill back there and how did things
change in your mind taylor the lawn well
i think the office one really started
getting a lot of chemistry obviously i
didn't help us at all by being suspended
for four weeks and you know roger and i
didn't get very much time to you know
figure out what his like what i can help
him with what he can help me with and
how we can mesh and be a better left
side of the office alive and we've we've
gotten better as the seasons gone the
more we played together i think that's
helped a little bit but honestly man you
know sometimes you look at back and say
well that guy he's a product of a good
zone reteam he's a product of this is
part of that I mean I've been with there
for four years now and we played in
different offices together gap schemes
and also outside zone team the guy is an
extremely talented individual and I
think that he's one of those guys or
whatever kind of office you put him in
he's going to be successful and so that
might heat that my hat goes off so man
I'm super happy for him he's one of my
favorite players it was played with I
love the guy yeah of course and you know
knowing that
he's coming downhill that just changes
the mindset of an offensive line that
you just go hit somebody right in front
of you and let him do the rest that must
be something yeah oh I've been I've been
hit by Derrick downhill and later it's
not fun
what do you mean there's been a there's
been a couple times as well a couple
times in practice you you know you turn
around or you think the play is over and
here comes Derrick dude he's a train man
he's he's a tractor for sure he just
comes and he will hit anything that's
moving and so he's that guy he'll get a
yard he'll get 50 he's got the speed to
get 50 and he's got the strength to get
a yard and I think it's really
impressive very impressive
now again III know again there is a
sensitivity to the question when I asked
about Tannehill because you know Mariota
is your guy too and has been for a long
time but why has the offense seemed to
click with Tannehill back there you know
that's one of those I have no idea I
really don't because that's way above my
pay grade of I don't even know the first
if you put me in at quarterback we do in
16 so I don't even know how to have to
do that I can play a left tackle I'm
living a one-trick pony and that is it I
split left tackle right I think no
Tannehill has the experience of you know
he's gone through the ups and downs
obviously was a first-round pick the
Dolphins and he was in a quarterback
race back in the day and she had some
success got a big contract and then he
get traded and you're a backup and he's
dealt with a lot of stuff and I think
you know during the preseason when I was
wondering what to choose I remember just
sitting there thinking man this guy
really works the pocket he can he throws
it on time and he's got he's got a he's
got a confidence about him that's you
know I think it rubs off on people
she'll come in every single week
Treville gives us no keys to the game
an offensive keys will be whatever they
are and before I be drive while I'll
come in and point the other line say hey
remember this key Haley people remember
that key mm-hmm and kind of like gives
us that here let's get going let's get
in and he's just it is a great job men
are often terror low on titans offensive
linemen three-time pro-bowler right here
on the Rich Eisen show you mentioned for
Abel what a big week this is for him to
be in the playoffs
for the first time as a head coach and
of all places for him to go New England
where he won three championships and
also in back-to-back Super Bowls was a
surprise touchdown target for Tom Brady
I mean this guy is lionized up there any
sense at all about what you think this
means to him this week Taylor lon well
I'm sure it means a lot to him to go up
but he still really good friends of Tom
you know I think when we practice
against them this year Tom got him a
little present a little gag gift trophy
and they they were laughing and joking
with each other and yeah he's got a lot
of respect for those guys I mean any
time you've seen a team like that who
has had so much success in the last you
know decade it's or two decades really
like it it's really it's something you
you admire even from afar when we were
practicing against them I was there
anybody in a band that's Tom Brady how
cool is that guys on the same field as
him I think but I think when it comes to
raise man he's a he's focused on this
win and I think you know this is the
biggest game of our franchise because
this is first our playoff this is a
playoff game and so we need to take care
of this business and just keep moving
forward and taking stacking the
confidence that we have built throughout
the season and continue the momentum
into this first game what was the gag
gift
what happened with the trophy all that
brave I will tell you if he wants to
tell you but it was Alan Biasi was kind
of funny it was a good little it was a
good shirt by Tom okay a good shirt by
Tom and he presented it in front of both
teams
he actually present oh yeah I think you
on the side and then I walked in his
office and his laugh and he pointed at
it you know were able to paint the
picture for you it was very good it was
a beautiful team between two good
friends well it is again like I
mentioned
rables first game as a head coach in the
playoffs however it is not yours and a
bunch of other players that were there a
couple of years ago first playoff stand
and not the first playoff game in
Foxborough also how much do you think
that experience for anybody who was
there will be helpful this weekend that
it's not a new playoff environment for
you and them
yeah I think I mean that was a little
wild playoff run for us going to go into
Kansas City and being down 21 to 3 at
half and then coming back and winning
that game when nobody expect everybody
wrote us off at that at the half you
know I think I'm gonna play the Patriots
did you're not going to be surprised by
anything there are damn good team and
their defensive sound they play
extremely well that's like gap sound
defense and they'll play a lot of
different kind of Defense's that you
have to prepare for in a short week and
I mean they're they're fans are awesome
they have a great atmosphere
Gillette seen a lot of wins and so he's
got to go in there with the mindset you
just got to try to steal something from
them and they they they're extremely
good and I know people are talking as if
they you know they're not the same team
that I feel like every single year of
the past five years they've been trying
to say Tom's not the same guy and he
just thought he proves them all wrong so
we can't go in there with the thought
that they're you know less of a team and
they had been before you got to go and
you got to play your best ball because
if you don't play your best well Kyle
van Noy says it's a revenge game for
them because you guys beat them last
regular season 34 to 10 and that this is
a great way for them to get fired up
okay no it's four rings you talk to me
about we're ready game all right Dan
also and he is a here to guess on
bustled with the voice of strawberry
five stars very proud of Kyle van Noy in
the season that he's had great guy great
individual looking forward to going
against him in a couple of days so you
dismiss the concept that this is a
revenge game for the defending Super
Bowl champion New England Patriots boy
yeah you you lost our game in this in
this season and you wonder won the
Superbowl there's no revenge anything do
you do you reject that concept that
mental game play you tell that's a load
of bull the family show so I'm not going
to finish this oh man you know I have
spoken to a bunch of offensive linemen
who have faced a Belichick defensive
coordinator or influenced team and and
how they do
certainly reserved different things that
you haven't seen that you might spend
three you know you may spend several
practices working on three different
schemes that you think's coming at you
and then they use a fourth they uncork a
fourth or a fifth that they might have
used only once before
I'm sure if variable knows all about
that is that sort of a cat-and-mouse
scenario being discussed with you right
now
yeah I'm sure I'm sure it is I'm
actually I'm going into the building in
just a couple of minutes and we'll have
our team meeting and sit down and we'll
go everything but I played the Patriot
this is my fourth time playing them I
think third or fourth time and that'd be
like they have great football players on
their defense I think I heard I don't
want to say a degree because I don't
want to insult somebody but I heard some
guy commentating a football game with
the Patriots and he said basically a
bunch of no-name guys which once again
is a load of bull useful on the rest
those guys are talented they're well
known and they know what they're doing
but their defense would they do a really
good job of it and this is not a slight
or anything but it's kind of spend the
dialect what are we going to run this
week and they kind of have this big
giant circular device may spin it and
there's that clicking right okay we're
running bear this we go we're running
three four this is all running for three
this week you know and so it's kind of
like you know you kind of prepared for
everything going into this and the way
they play those blocks based on the week
you know and then you can say well
they've done this against outside zone
teams or systems gasping teams and also
does a good job of mixing up both you
know we have we kind of run every kind
of offense in our offense and I think
Arthur's been a good job of calling
those to keep other teams balanced again
and running sideways and get one down
held and the play-action opens up the
rest of it so before I let you go Taylor
as you go walk into the building to get
ready for the wildcard playoff game
against New England on Saturday night
for the whole country to be sitting
there and watching maybe you know
running backs get their offensive
linemen a gift maybe Derek Henry for
winning the rushing title behind you and
your your your mates maybe he gets your
mates something else and he gets you the
engine for bus and with the boys what do
you think about that idea
I tell you I've already already bought
it
I've already bought the engine what is
it and so the engine is now as we're
talking about now rich so once you
listen very closely okay as these words
are coming out of my mouth yes there's
an engine being placed into the bus
real-time now will and I have already
talked long and hard about this okay if
soon is that bus is running I'm not
going to drive it to LA because I'm not
wasting those kind of miles on a new
engine okay I may get that baby [ __ ] and
gets wrong coming I'm coming over to see
you the recharge you me and all the
quickly you have okay so right now but
what's the engine can you tell me what
the exact engine that's going in the
diesel Cummins engine actually okay and
please don't make me go any further than
that no it's okay it's beautiful it's
gonna run great pops right in okay i guy
named Joe agents putting it in for me
right now right at this moment so what
is Derek Henry getting everybody or has
he gotten everybody well I I think what
I hope he gets me a grill because I
think that would be hilarious to play
football at the grill and I've never had
a grill before he meant for the bus I
thought that's what you meant the grill
grill for the bus no I meant like a
gorilla I want to create a gang as they
say I got it so he hasn't bought you
anything is what you're saying not yet
well I mean it happened a day and a half
ago so I'm okay Derek's confident
confident God but I think we all win in
a game not knowing if that was really a
possibility because Charlie had about 75
or 80 yards more than Derek's going into
this game and then I'll tell you what
when god when he gets going man you know
the three yards turn into six and then
the six turns into 60 and it's amazing I
mean it's just when he gets going the
business decisions get much much more or
easier I guess for defenders it's
amazing it really is Matt it really is
he you just get to turning man and the
thing is he's mad if he
for your game he's pissed because they
hand to him every single situation
there's an opportunity for a touchdown
there and so you see that you're like I
want to get this guy that touchdown see
I don't want to deal with their a matt
darey you have no one want to deal with
a Matt Derek mm and yeah I tell you what
in the first half of that game here like
66 yards rushing in the first half which
is good you know then you double that
right that's one what 1:32 I'm not great
at math but can I put it
yes he he came out and he just ran twice
as hard man that guy is he's an absolute
workhorse she's a great person he
deserves every single accomplishment he
gets yeah 211 yards rushing in the big
win for for the Titans and again the
difference between 66 and 211 yards is
the difference between a podcast and a
bus with an engine and without without
so I'm glad you're getting this theory I
know it's my way of saying I'm glad that
you're getting this rectified and then I
will be the first planned scheduled if
you will to appear guest on lesson with
the boys in a bus with an engine in it
and I would be honored to be that person
actually be I'd be insulted if it was
somebody else Taylor I'll be honest well
I mean the way things have been going
out and I just might go 5050 at this
point sounds good
dearly you yes in college they're not
nearly as good as a guest as me I'll
tell you that whoever that person might
actually be good luck in New England
brother I'll be I'll be watching
I'll be watching we'll chat soon happy
New Year to you happy New Year to you
and yours that's Taylor low on offensive
line with Tennessee Titans right here in
the Rich Eisen show never disappointing
is the guest for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR Live or download
the Rich Eisen show app